like we're never quite sure who we are  you know okay well i've written some  books but like am i really an author or  did i just get lucky a couple of times  we like and need for other people around  us to to kind of validate those  discoveries you know things that we  can't see in ourselves they see in us  and this is this is what intimacy is  it's it's when your discovery of  yourself matches somebody else's  perception of you wait say that again  say that again nice and slow intimacy is  when your discovery of yourself or your  perception of yourself is matched by  somebody who sees you the same way and  it's what what binds us together you  know all these crazy emotions that we  all struggle to deal with like  ultimately a lot of their purpose  is  to make us all  attached to one another feel attached to  one another and want to sacrifice and  help one another and  that's what makes our species so  successful